last question today is from ray ray says
hey David have you met people who were
just really off-putting or mean for no
apparent reason how do you deal with
them you know my view on this has really
changed over time when I was younger and
I would meet someone that was just
really off-putting overly aggressive
mean I would often have very very
negative reactions about the person and
I would sort of immediately dislike the
person and feel anger resentment in and
uh really sort of go in a way where when
they say something that is off-putting
or mean try to match that and respond in
kind but over the years I sort of
realized that it's very rare that
there's genuinely bad people and for the
most part when somebody is off-putting
or mean or very arrogant or aggressive
in social situations I actually kind of
feel bad because it usually is
indicative of the fact that they're
either really insecure or it could lead
to lead from having been neglected as
kids and this is how they sort of seek
attention and validation they could have
something going on in their life where
they've experienced a loss could be a
breakup could be a death in the family
whatever and this is an attitude that
they're sort of taking for
self-protection I don't know Pat I mean
over time I i I'm much more sympathetic
to people like that and I say you know
something really tough must be going on
for someone to show up and recently I
had someone show up in a group of people
they didn't really they knew a couple of
the people they didn't know me and they
were just very off-putting very
dismissive and condescending in whatever
if they're feeling the need to do that
it's probably representative of some
issue they have going on and it doesn't
really have anything to do with with
wanting to attack me plus it's important
important to point out where we live too
which is Boston and this city gets the
reputation of being awfully aggressive
and when you come across someone who is
just overly aggressive and and
off-putting I guess as the questions
phrase yeah it's hard not to match their
level totally and ed you bluest told
some stories of dealing with litterers
on the way to the studio and he would
choose to get pretty aggressive and I
don't know of littering littering could
be you just don't care about your
surroundings but littering also could be
because of how you grew up you just
don't really think about tossing your
Dunkin Donuts copper starbucks cup or
whatever on on the ground because you
grew up in a situation where maybe
they're the trash was dealt with in that
way I don't know so I try not to be too
reactive in generally speaking I'm not
the type to escalate situations so I am
NOT gonna be the one who says what do
you think you are talking to me in that
way you know it's just I try to just
play it cool if this is not someone that
I want to be around then I just can
quietly not participate in conversation
with these people that's usually my move
I don't know how you react around people
like that yeah just keep the
conversation short only say what you
need to and go about your day I totally
agree with you and I'm I'd I know there
are people in the audience at least from
what they claim when they email me who
often take very aggressive approaches
when they are confronted with an opinion
they don't like and whatever I'd be
curious to hear has that ever led to
anything positive cuz it my more
aggressive youthful days rarely when I
would come back at aggression with
aggression would ever really accomplish
anything rarely would I change any minds
rarely would I achieve someone changing
their demeanor towards me just didn't
really make any sense and I I think I
learned from that pretty early on we
have a fantastic bonus show for you
today david pakman.com slash bonus show
is how you sign up get instant access
and of course that's the number one
funding source for the program so I
would really encourage you if you like
the work we do you want to support
independent media sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership